I've got an arbitrary function here and
what we're going to try to do is
approximate this arbitrary function we
don't know what it is using a polynomial
we'll keep adding terms to that
polynomial but to do this we're going to
assume that we can evaluate the function
at 0 that it gives us some value and
that we can't eat that we can keep
taking the derivative of the function
and evaluating the the first the second
and the third derivatives so on and so
forth at 0 as well so we're assuming
we're assuming that we know what f of 0
is we're assuming that we know what F
prime of 0 is we're assuming that we
know the second derivative at 0 we're
assuming that we know the third
derivative at 0 so maybe I'll write it
third derivative I'll just write F prime
prime at 0 so forth and so on so let's
think about how we can approximate this
using polynomials of ever-increasing
lengths so if we could have a polynomial
just one term and would just be a
constant term so this would be a
polynomial of degree 0 and if we have a
constant term we at least might want to
make that that constant polynomial it
really is just a constant function equal
the function at f of 0 so at first maybe
we just want P of 0 where Pala note the
putt where P is a polynomial that we're
going to construct we want P of 0 to be
equal to F of 0 so if we want to do that
using a polynomial of only one term of
only one constant term we can just set
we can just set P of X is equal to F of
0 so if I were to graph it it would look
like this it would just be a horizontal
line at F of 0 and you could say Sal
that's a horrible approximation it only
approximates the function at this point
it looks like we got lucky at a couple
of other points but it's really bad
everywhere else and I would tell you
well try to do any better using a
horizontal line at least we got it right
at F of 0 so this is about as this is
about as good as we can do with just a
constant and even though I just want to
remind you this might not look like a
constant but we're assuming that given
the function we can evaluate it at 0 and
that'll just give us a number so
whatever number that was we would put it
right over here and we'd say P of X is
equal to that number it would just be a
horizontal line right there
at F of zero but that obviously is not
so great so let's add some more
constraints beyond the fact that we want
P of 0 to be equal to F of 0 let's say
that we also want we also want P Prime
at 0 to be the same thing as F Prime at
0 let me do this in a new color so we
also want in the new color we also want
that's not a new color we also want P
Prime we want the first derivative of
our polynomial what evaluated at 0 to be
the same thing as the first derivative
of the function when evaluated at 0 and
we don't want to lose this right over
here so what if what if we set P of X as
being equal to f of 0 so we're taking
our old P of X but now we're going to
add another term so the derivatives
match up Plus F prime of 0 times X so
let's think about this a little bit if
we use this as our new polynomial what
happens P what is P of 0 P of 0 is going
to be equal to you're going to have F of
0 F of 0 plus whatever this derivative F
prime of 0 is x 0 right if you put a 0
in for X this term is just going to be 0
so you're going to be left with P of 0
is equal to f of 0 that's cool that's
just as good as our first version now
what's the derivative over here so the
derivative is P prime P prime of X is
equal to take the derivative of this
this is just a constant so it's
derivative is 0
the derivative of a coefficient times X
is just going to be the coefficient so
it's going to be F prime of 0 so if you
evaluate it at 0 so P prime of 0 or the
derivative of our polynomial evaluated
at 0 I know it's a little weird because
we're not using you know we're doing all
P prime of X of F of 0 and all of this
but just remember what's the variable
what's the constants and hopefully it'll
make sense so this is just obviously
going to be F prime of 0 its derivative
is a constant value this is a constant
value right here we're assuming that we
could take the derivative of our
function and evaluate that thing at 0
to give a constant value so if you
deprive of X is equal to this constant
value obviously P prime of X evaluated
at zero is going to be that value but
what's cool about what's cool about this
right here
this polynomial that has a zero degree
term and a first degree term is now this
polynomial is equal to our function at X
is equal to zero and it also has the
same first derivative it also has the
same slope at X is equal to zero so this
thing will look this new polynomial with
two terms getting a little bit better it
will look it will look something like
that it will essentially it will
essentially have it look like a tangent
line at F at F of zero at X is equal to
zero so we're doing better but still not
a super good approximation it kind of
goes is going in the same general
direction as our function around zero
but maybe we can do better by making
sure that they have the same second
derivative and to try to have the same
second derivative while still having the
same first derivative and the same value
at zero let's try to do that let's try
to do something interesting let's define
let's define P of X so this let's make
it clear this was our first try this is
our second try right over here and I'm
about to embark on our third dry so our
third try my goal is that the value of
my polynomial is the same as the value
of the function at 0 they have the same
derivative at 0 and they also have the
same second derivative at 0 so let's
define my polynomial to be equal to so
I'm going to do the first two terms of
these guys right over here so it's going
to be it's going to be f of 0 plus F
prime of 0 times X so exactly what we
did here but now let me add another term
I'll do the other term in a new color
plus plus and I'm going to put a 1/2 out
here and hopefully it might make sense
why I'm about to do this plus 1/2 times
f the second derivative of our function
evaluated at 0 x squared and when we
evaluate the derivative of this I think
you'll see why this
one half is there because now let's
evaluate let's evaluate this and its
derivatives at zero so if we evaluate P
of 0 P of 0 is going to be equal to what
well you have this constant term if you
evaluate at 0 this X and this x squared
are both going to be 0 so those terms
going to go away so P of 0 is still
equal to F of 0 if you take the
derivative of P of X so let me take the
derivative right here I'll do it in
yellow so the derivative of my new P of
X is going to be equal to so this term
is going to go away it's a constant term
it's going to be equal to F prime of 0
that's the coefficient on this plus tape
this is the power rule right here 2
times 1/2 is just 1 plus F prime prime
of 0 times X take the 2 multiply it
times 1/2 and decrement that 2 right
there and I think you now have a sense
of why we put the 1/2 there it's kind of
counter it's it's it's it's making it so
that we don't end up with the 2
coefficient out front now what is P
prime of 0 so let me write it right here
P prime of 0 is what well this term
right here is just going to be 0 so just
you're left with this constant value
right over here so it's going to be F
prime of 0 so so far our third
generation polynomial has all the
properties of the first two and let's
see how it does on the third on its
third derivative so let's see so if we
are so I should say the second
derivative so pre P prime prime of X is
equal to this is a constant so it's
derivative is 0 so then you just take
the coefficient on the second term is
equal to F prime prime of 0 so what's
the second derivative of P evaluated 0
well it's just going to be this constant
value it's going to be F prime prime of
0 so notice by adding this term now not
only is our the is our a polynomial
value the same thing as our function
value at 0 its derivative at 0 is the
same thing as our as the derivative of
the function at 0 and it's second
derivative at 0 is the same thing as the
second derivative of the function at 0
so we're getting pretty good at this and
you might guess that there's a pattern
here we could every term we add
add it'll allow us it'll allow us to set
up the situation so that the the nth
derivative of our approximation at 0
will be the same thing as the nth
derivative of our function at 0 so in
general if we wanted to keep doing this
if we had a lot of time on our hands and
we wanted to just keep adding terms to
our polynomial we could and let me do
this in a new color maybe I'll do it in
a color I already used we could make our
polynomial approximation we could make
our problem on polynomial approximation
so the first term the constant term will
just be f of zero then the next term
will be F prime of zero times X then the
next term will be F prime prime of 0
times 1/2 times x squared I just rewrote
that in a slightly different order then
the next term if we want to make their
third derivatives the same at zero would
be F prime prime prime of zero the third
derivative of the function at zero times
one half times one third so 1 over 2
times 3 times X to the third and we can
keep going maybe you'll start to see a
pattern here plus if we want to make
their fourth derivatives at zero
coincide it would be the fourth
derivative of the function I could put a
four up there but this is really
emphasizing it's the fourth derivative
at zero times one over and I'll change
the order instead of writing in
increasing order I'll write it as 4
times 3 times 2 times times X to the
fourth and you can verify it for
yourself if we just had this only and if
you were taking the fourth derivative of
this evaluate it at 0 it'll be the same
thing as the fourth derivative of the
function evaluated at 0 and in general
you can keep adding terms where the nth
term will look like this the nth
derivative of your function evaluated at
0 times X to the N over over N factorial
notice this is the same thing as 4
factorial 4 factorial is equal to 4
times 3 times 2 times 1 you don't have
to write the 1 there but it you could
put it there
this right here is the same thing as 3
factorial 3 times 2 times 1 I didn't put
the 1 there this right here is the same
thing as 2 factorial 2 times 1 this is
the same thing we didn't do write
anything but you could divide this by 1
factorial which is the same thing as 1
and so and you could divide this by 0
factorial which also happens to be 1 we
won't have to study it too much over
here but this general series that that
I've kind of set up right here is called
the Maclaurin series Maclaurin series
and you can approximate a polynomial and
we'll see at least of some pretty
powerful results later on but what
happens and I don't have the computing
power in my brain to draw the graph
properly is that the when you when only
the function is equal you get that
horizontal line when you make the
functions and the function at when you
make the function equal at 0 and their
first derivative is equal to 0 then you
have something that looks like the
tangent line when you add another degree
it might approximate the polynomial
something like this when you add another
degree it might look something it might
look something like that and as you keep
adding more and more degrees it get
starts or when you keep adding more and
more terms it gets closer and closer
around especially as you get close to X
is equal to 0 but in theory if you add
an infinite number of terms you
shouldn't be able to I haven't proven
this to you so that's why I'm saying
it's in theory I haven't proved it yet
to you but if you had an infinite number
of terms it should be all of the
derivatives should be the same and then
the the the function should pretty much
look like each other in the next video
I'll do this with some actual functions
just so it makes a little bit more sense
and just so you know the Maclaurin
series is a special case of the Taylor
series because we're centering it at 0
and when you're doing a Taylor series
you could pick any center point but
we'll focus on the Maclaurin we'll focus
on the Maclaurin right now